next one oh my god
next one in
next one in please got it
but
take somebody help me
selena gomez squirms as gordon ramsay
shouts
oh my goodness it all went down on
selena's hbo max series selena plus chef
welcome
where she learns how to make delicious
dishes i want to make things great new
mouthwatering recipes masterful chefs
and a few funny mishaps along the way
funny mishaps well you could say that
again cell's latest guest uh kind of
loses it gordon is showing off his
signature color commentary that there is
an idiot sandwich when selena
accidentally cooks the food in the wrong
pan at wrong pan that's my non-stick pan
for my potatoes
sorry
the second one okay next one in
yeah and selena she tries her best to
cook it the right way next one oh my god
next one in
next one in please
take somebody help me help me but all
that drama is quickly forgotten when
selena and gordon laugh off the mistake
hey you down there sunbathing next one
in please
oh my god i'm sorry thank you i'm not
that great but i did a good job i think
it's okay cell we still love you despite
those skills in the kitchen
[Music]
and when selena's not turning up the
heat in that kitchen she's sizzling in
just about all aspects of her life and
her slate is stacked she's working on a
reboot of working girl i like to to come
at things with my best and will soon be
back on set for only murders in the
building season 3. this ends the
investigation into a whole new direction
we hope it will take us to clues
it's a wall and suspects so what do we
know about my daughter's murder maybe
she killed bunny you think that woman
stabbed so many times
we'll put a pin in her for now and don't
worry not only is selena crushing it in
the career department but in her
personal life too
thank you i appreciate i try she's 30
and loving life i'm 30
and um i'm so far enjoying it yeah and
we'll be over here enjoying this funny
moment with gordon
next one oh my god
next one in next one in please got it
but
take somebody help me
[Music]